wenn man diese erfahrung selbst gemacht
hat das wird oft den ganzen schmerz den
man selbst erlebt hat noch einmal auf
wie geht es dir damit du hast völlig
recht patricia mir ging es so damit als
kritikern so offen und so schonungslos
ehrlich über ihre fehlgeburt gesprochen
hatte wie sie vor kurzem lagen musste
und uns auch diese bilder lieferte aus
dem krankenhaus wie es ihr ging wie sie
geweint hat und ich gehe schwer davon
aus dass merkel nicht besser dran war
psychisch das macht ja was mit einem bei
mir war es so ich habe mein kind ins
bett gebracht und hatte eine
schmerzvolle nacht und am nächsten
morgen ging das ganze los und es ist wie
merkel sagt man ist in einer ganz
normalen position man macht ganz normale
dinge der alltag muss ja weiter
funktionieren und zwischendurch verdient
man ein kind das ist schnell gesagt und
und ganz leicht aber es ist genauso
und es ist so hart wie sie es schreibt
man umklammert sein erstes kind und das
zweite verliert man und ich sage so wie
es ist es ist wunderschön dass sie den
mut drüber gefunden hatte zu sprechen
und jede frau hat an ihre eigene
geschichte und die sind oftmals hart und
sie sind genauso hart und bei kristin
und offen gestanden ist es so ein ball
des kindes jetzt sprichwörtlich die
toilette herunter einteiligen die rose
und der letzte teil landet auf dem op
tisch und was das mit jemandem machen da
in dieser haut möchte man einfach nicht
stecken ich freue mich für jeden ihr
diese erfahrung nicht machen muss ich
finde es aber auch ganz toll dass sie in
ihrer position mit mit ihrer
öffentlichkeitswirkung so offen darüber
schreibt das nimmt vielen frauen die
angst darüber zu sprechen so war es bei
mir und kritiken sie hat sich durch ihre
offenheit mir ein tor geöffnet dass ich
gesagt habe ja hier ist es auch so
passiert und warum soll ich eigentlich
darüber den mund halten
richtig so lass es raus es gab so karen
waren schweigen so viele frauen was
später eine rolle es ist scham es ist
trauer
warum wird so wenig darüber gesprochen
gleich
seit ich aber schaffen es jetzt doch
viele frauen den mut zu fassen über
diese schmerzhafte ereignis zu sprechen
naja es ist einmal die sache dass es ist
nicht leicht ja man hat praktisch ja
noch nichts greifbares in der hand oder
wenn man was in der hand hat dann lebt
es halt nicht mehr so und und wir tun
uns schwer mit dem tod tun uns absolut
schwer darüber zu reden das leben ein
ende hat das leben nicht ewig dauert ja
wir vermitteln dass physisch kann man
das machen man kann erde drauf tun im
wahrsten sinne des wortes die psyche wie
kann man eben nicht verbuddeln und das
dauert es ist oft ein makel gewesen zu
sagen ich brauche hilfe ich auch eine
therapie ich muss darüber reden es geht
nicht ohne
ich kann das nicht einfach mit mir
machen und dann ist die zweite sache ja
man muss ja weiter funktionieren jetzt
wie in meggen style oder auch in meinem
fall es gibt ja schon ein kind das kind
es ja da das kind ist oftmals noch so
jung das ist das nicht versteht mein
kind fragte mich als ich wieder aus dem
krankenhaus kam mama ist das baby jetzt
nicht mehr an seinem bau ich sag nein
und dann kämpft man natürlich mit den
tränen und dann hat man so ein kleines
wesen vorsicht das dann sagt aber mama
du hast doch mich noch ja man möchte
auch nicht weinen man möchte nicht mehr
vor seinem kleinen kind weint man möchte
jeden touristen bin ich sicher man ist
für jeden da und man hat ja auch
geschildert die erste frage ging an
harry bist du okay
ja man macht sich über alles sorgen wenn
man erst mal mutter ist und kümmert sich
das ist wahrscheinlich so umgehen dass
frauen da haben die meisten jedenfalls
und ja wenn man weiter funktioniert und
nicht gerne über den tod spricht
verdrängt man das was eigentlich nötig
ist über zu regen den mund auf zu
kriegen die dinge zu verarbeiten
das ist ein ereignis das kann man eben
nicht mit einem paar meter erde
verbuddeln
es gibt nichts was hat dir in dieser
zeit geholfen um über diesen verlust
hinwegzukommen
ich muss offen gestehen mein kind und
dass ich weiter funktionieren muss das
kann ja auch eine hilfe sein so etwas ja
dass man eine aufgabe hat nicht sich
selbst überlassen haben wird
und ja dinge machen muss alltag alltag
hilft viel
das stimmt aber sobald man eine pause
hat und zum nachdenken kommt ist das
ganze schon vorbei dann kommen die
tränen dann rollen sie und und man muss
lernen sie auch rollen zu lassen sie
traurigkeit muss genauso ein recht im
leben haben sich sich der ausdruck zu
finden wie fröhliches lachen ja dass das
ist wichtig und man muss lernen und
akzeptieren zu sagen ich brauche hilfe
dafür braucht man ein reines kann sein
der eine länger der nächste nicht so
aber es ist keine scham um hilfe zu
fragen
ich meine die deutschen wir können das
nicht so gut ich weiß nicht warum das so
ist aber es ist so dass steckt in jedem
uns drin das ist genau das gleiche wie
wir uns auch noch mit einer dicken
erkältung zur arbeit schleppen wir haben
viel disziplin in uns und zu viel das
ist nicht gut wir müssen da von dieser
disziplin ein bisschen runterkommen und
und von der strenge und selbst gegenüber
und sagen wir brauchen hilfe
und es muss weitergehen und es kann
geholfen werden und darüber zu reden den
mund auf jedem ehrlich zu sagen dazu
dass es mir passiert das leben ist nicht
nur eitel sonnenschein das ist nicht
eine über eine wiese zu gehen und
gänseblümchen pflücken es ist auch im
wahrsten sinne des wortes manchmal sehr
dunkel aber genau wenn man diese
dunkelheit anspricht nur das hilft ist
dass die sonne auch wieder scheinen kann
so ab wie das klingt aber es ist so aber
den schritt dorthin zu machen das ist
nicht leicht und ich freue mich dass
merkel den schritt gemacht hat ich freue
mich dass positiven diesen schritt
gemacht hat wenn es hilft ungemein
vielen vielen betroffenen sich zu öffnen
und solche sachen die so schwer zu
verarbeiten sind irgendwie in den griff
zu kriegen
jedes zweite frau in deutschland macht
diese schmerzhafte erfahrung einer
fehlgeburt und auch an der wilken
wir kennen sie aus germany's next
topmodel hat diese schmerzhafte
erfahrung durchleben müssen sie es uns
jetzt zugeschaltet und auch sie findet
den mut über dieses erlebnis zu sprechen
hallo anna wie geht es ihnen jetzt
wenn sie diese nachrichten von megan
merkel hören
geht man dann das erlebte noch mal neu
erst mal hallo und also persönlich
erlebe ich das erlebte nicht noch mal
neu aber ich finde das sehr stark und
einfach total mutig und schön darüber zu
sprechen da auch wenn man eben in der
öffentlichkeit ist weil das nichts ist
wofür man sich schämen sollten
ich habe immer das gefühl dass zu
fehlgeburten und einfach so und den
teppich gekehrt werden und das immer nur
über das positive gesprochen wird einer
schwangerschaft aber fakt ist einfach
dass viele frauen auch langen weg haben
will schwanger werden und halt eben wie
auch gerade schon gesagt wurde man davon
ausgeht dass jede zweite frau eine
fehlgeburt hat und das ist einfach
unglaublich viel beschreibe uns wie es
für dich jetzt ist darüber zu sprechen
hat man da auch gewisse ängste fühlt man
charme und vor allem was hilft dir dabei
optimistisch in die zukunft zu blicken
beim thema kinderwunsch
also mir hat tatsächlich geholfen
darüber zu sprechen das war für mich so
für mich stand fest dass sich irgendwann
darüber sprechen werde
und das habe ich auch gemacht und das
kam total gut weil ich das alles so
losgeworden bin und weil man halt eben
auch von vielen frauen so viel zuspruch
bekommen hat eben weil man nicht alleine
ist und ich finde wenn man nicht darüber
spricht und sich auch vielleicht im
bekanntenkreis dafür schämen was ich zum
beispiel gar nicht getan habe und ich
bin da auch nicht dass man zu tun muss
dann erlöst es einen schon einfach so
ein bisschen und man hört von anderen
das feedback und man fühlt sich dadurch
nicht mehr so alleine
auch wenn das natürlich die tatsache an
sich nicht verschönert wenn man so eine
nachricht bekommt dass man ein kind
verliert dass die schwangerschaft nicht
weitergeht was ging dir da durch den
kopf was ging dir durchs herz und was
kannst du anderen frauen raten
vielleicht die sich in ähnlichen
situationen befinden
also mir hat das mein herz
herausgerissen
das hat die schlimmste erfahrung die ich
je gemacht habe einfach weil also wir
auch schon mit bayern in der
kinderwunschbehandlung sind und ich
nicht so gefreut hat dass es endlich
geklappt hat und ich dachte so hey was
soll passieren dass das glück wird nicht
weggehen und
als ich das dann erfahren habe ich das
war wie in so ein film also ich war
gefühlt gar nicht anwesend und mir hat
es geholfen einfach darüber zu reden und
ich glaube es ist super schwierig da
einfachen tipps zu geben und zu sagen so
hey mach das und die wird es besser
gehen
das muss man leider selber einfach dann
durch leben aber mir hat das reden
geholfen ich habe mir meinen freundinnen
geredet und meiner mutter mit meinem
freund ich habe aber auch mich
eingesperrt geweint und nicht gesprochen
also ich habe einfach alles gemacht was
mir in dem moment irgendwie gut hat auch
das thema unerfüllter kinderwunsch ist
ja für viele ganz schwierig zu
besprechen ist es oft eine achterbahn
der gefühle der hoffnungen der
enttäuschten hoffnungen dass sich wieder
aufrappeln hoffen wie gehst du damit um
wie erlebst du das also aktuell bin ich
noch sehr positiv gestimmt und glaube
das ist irgendwann klappen wird nur weil
sich hat aktuell einfach noch nicht wann
und ich versuche mir immer als wie man
da rein zu halten das klar jeder weitere
zyklus kann man nicht schwanger geworden
ist irgendwo ein weiterer zyklus wo es
nicht geklappt hat aber jeder neue
zyklus der kommt das hat auch irgendwo
eine neue chance wieder schwanger zu
werden und da versuche ich einfach sehr
viel vertrauen mir zu haben und ich weiß
ich werde schwanger nur hat eben noch
nicht wann
hast du das gefühl du kannst bei einer
erneuten schwangerschaft so unbedarft in
diese schwangerschaft gehen wie du es
vielleicht bei meiner ersten
schwangerschaft getan hast also erst mal
schwanger war hatte ich schon natürlich
ängste am anfang ich habe wie gesagt
gedacht das glück wird uns schon bleiben
aber es war natürlich trotzdem da weil
ich eben weiß dass so etwas passieren
kann
ich weiß nicht wie ich jetzt reagieren
würde wenn ich noch mal schwanger wäre
ehrlich gesagt es kann sein dass ich
noch einige sicher bin es kann aber auch
sein dass ich das gar nicht bin weil ich
kanns ja eh nicht ändern also ich habe
keinen einfluss darauf
schonungslos mutig und offen spricht
märgen makel über ihre fehlgeburt die
sie im vergangenen sommer erleiden
musste
das ist nicht unbedingt typisch für
einen roll und darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit unserem royal experten alexander von
schönburg der bei mir im studio ist halo
alexander morgen wird es jetzt auch bei
den royals ein bisschen na ja fast schon
moderner dass man auch themen anspricht
die weh tun die ein angreifbar machen
ist das etwas was den weiß vielleicht
auch gut zu gesicht steht
interessante frage ich muss erstmal
verdauen was ich jetzt alles erfahren
habe und auch carens worte fand ich sehr
beeindruckend zu hören wie jemand ist
schildert und das beeindruckendste fand
ich tatsächlich auch die beim letzten
beitrag die tatsache dass es betroffenen
frauen offenbar so hilft wenn prominente
ob es wohl oder schauspieler oder andere
personen des öffentlichen lebens über
ihr leid sprechen und dadurch anderen
mut geben sozusagen da so ein ventil
sollen ventil öffnen das damit trauer
auch bewältigt bewältigt werden kann das
finde ich mal wahnsinnig interessant und
ich glaube die da eine frage zu
beantworten beiden rollt es ist ja in
ihm jetzt auch schon eine weile so dass
die rolls da schon so ein bisschen mit
kursänderungen mitgemacht haben also
william und harry haben sehr offen zum
beispiel über ihre über gemüts probleme
gesprochen nach dem tod ihrer mutter
dass sie das sieht dass die depression
gefallen sind sie haben sich dann
öffentlich eben auch mal machen eine
kampagne um eben über mentale gesundheit
da dieses sozusagen dieses tabuthema so
zu sein
ein bisschen in die öffentlichkeit zu
bringen und das ist glaube ich das
zentrale die zentrale aufgabe von allen
persönlichen personen des öffentlichen
lebens m themen in die öffentlichkeit zu
bringen die sonst zu vielleicht unter
den tisch gekehrt werden und durch ihr
persönliches leid und ihr persönliches
vorleben anderen menschen auch ja so
eine art orientierung zu geben
was glaubst du warum wird werden in der
öffentlichkeit das thema fehlgeburt so
oft verschwiegen wie geht es dir auch
als man damit wenn du hörst was sie
frauen die wir hier auch in der sendung
gehört haben berichten ist das ein
schmerz von dem man so gar nicht so
richtig ahnen konnte vorher ich sehr
sehr interessant was unsere kollegen
karin vorhin gesagt dass das thema
schlechthin etwas ist was sozusagen ins
unsichtbare geschoben wird dass das
etwas ist ich finde das zeigt im moment
auch so ein bisschen die krone krise
wissen wir leben in einer gesellschaft
die fitness und gesundheit und strahlend
und alles muss super seien immer so im
vordergrund stellt und die jugend usw
und dass das thema krankheit und tod so
auf die seite gedrängt und prob dann
doch irgendwie auf und kann dann auch
sozusagen auch irrationale irrationale
ängste schön wie karin ihm auch gesagt
hat das leben ist eben nicht kennen sie
blümchen pflücken auf der wii sitzung
zum leben gehört laut zum leben gehören
auch krankheiten und es gehört zu
unserer natur das bisschen unter den
teppich zu kehren
das ist deswegen noch mal es ist einfach
fantastisch dass mengen damit an die
öffentlichkeit gehe ich glaube sogar
dass sie damit eine gewisse veränderung
dass es sozusagen ein turning point sein
könnte für ihre beziehung zum englischen
bevölkerung wenn man darf nicht
vergessen die trennung sozusagen
zwischen mengen und großbritannien war
nicht sehr freundlich auf beiden seiten
also die menge hatte an interviews
gegeben sie zum teil gesagt hat er mir
sehr viel misstrauen und sogar rassismus
von der breiten bevölkerung irgendwie
sozialen netzen und so weiter zugetragen
worden und hat quasi gesagt ich fühle
mich nicht wohl in großbritannien
dadurch dass sie jetzt so offen über
ihre gefühle spricht ist das viel kann
man das auch deuten wie so eine art hand
ausstrecken über die den briten weil sie
damit ja wieder eine konversation mit
ihnen beginnt und was ist die intimste
konversation sowie seine eigenes leid zu
teilen darüber zu erzählen und ich
glaube es wird ihn natürlich aus
großbritannien
sehr sehr viel mitgefühl entgegenkommen
ich bin sicher dass der premierminister
heute im unterhaus wird bevor über
politik redet wird erst mal sagen das
mitgefühl des ganzen landes mengen
ausdrücken und wird damit etwas zum
ausdruck bringen was sicher in
großbritannien absolut präsent ist
dieses wird auf diese junge dame jetzt
anders schauen und der umgang mit ihr
wird auch ein anderer sein dadurch dass
sie die kraft hatte so ihre innersten
schmerzen außen zu kehren
wie glaubst du willst dir emily darauf
reagieren sie ist bekannt für ihre stiff
upper lip ist es nicht unbedingt normal
dort über gefühle zu sprechen
sie hat ja auch trotzdem die new york
times als medium gewählt um dieses thema
zu thematisieren also sie hat sich da
schon auch noch mal von harrys heimat
abgegrenzt meinst du dass die auch mit
offenen armen sie in dieser
schmerzvollen lage empfangen
oder er wird es da hinter vorgehaltener
hand vielleicht auch wieder wie so oft
kritik für morgen geben also das
klischee dass die königsfamilie so
schrecklich herzlos und stiff upper lip
sei ist natürlich etwas was wie gesagt
im klischee ist und vor allem geprägt
ist auch durch das schreckliche schauen
von dieser schrecklichen serie der
frauen und die königsfamilie als herzlos
karikiert wird es ist in wahrheit
natürlich vollkommen anders
ich habe vor paar tagen erst wieder
darüber nachdenken müssen wegen frauen
weil dort die der adressaten karton laut
mountbatten geschildert wird dass büchel
nicht raus aber weil auch sein enkelsohn
dabei umgekommen ist der 14 jahre alt
war
sein bruder wurde schwer verletzt über
den bruder habe ich eben neulich kontakt
gehabt und der erzählte dass er nach
diesem attentat sein bruder war
gestorben sein sein sein onkel war
gestorben sind er hat dieses attentat
auf dieser bot an der küste irlands
überlebt und ist nach balmoral gekommen
zur zur königin und die königin erzählt
er habe sich um ihn gekümmert wie so
eine mutter hätte ihn ständig tee
gemacht und honig rein gerührt und ihnen
den arm genommen und so weiter also wenn
man so etwas hört widerspricht das doch
dann war sehr dem bild das einem
sozusagen so fernsehserien wie the crown
oder sozusagen vermitteln
selbstverständlich wird die ep die aus
der königsfamilie sind sehr sehr eng
verbundener familienverbund mit ihrer
liebe
und und und und mitgefühl entgegen gehen
und auch für ihre beziehung zum
königshaus kann so ein leid so schlimm
ist ist auch ein weg zurück sein zu
einer arbeit sozusagen wieder ein
gespräch anfängst miteinander
man hat megan ihr kind verloren aber
auch harry hat ja sein zweites kind
verloren was denkst du wie geht er damit
um
also ich glaube und das wirklich
beurteilen zu können dass der schmerz
für eine mutter unvergleichbar ist man
das als vater nicht nachvollziehen kann
in den vollen ausmaß weil es wächst ein
kind wächst nicht in unserem körper
heran
und das heißt auch schon rein körperlich
ist die bindung nicht die gleiche ich
glaube herr ist wichtigste aufgabe
moment ist ihr die stütze zu sein die
die große stütze zu sein
matrimonial also das lateinische wort
für er heißt zusagen schutz der frau das
ist in dem moment muss ja ganz stark an
ihrer seite sein jemand an den sie sich
anlehnen kann und die auch emotionalen
support gibt und vor allem auch zuhörer
das fällt uns männern auf bisschen
schwer
wir wollen ein baby männer wollen immer
alles gleich fix tun wir wollen einen
wollen gleich eine lösung für alles und
in solchen momenten muss man einfach
seiner frau einfach nur zuhören und die
ohren aufmachen und sein herz öffnen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren